ontario is bearing the brunt of
disruptions from ottawa to the border
crossings but one major political figure
has been out of sight premier ford
issued a statement that the ongoing
illegal occupation and blockade
happening in ontario must stop adding
that he's confident our police forces in
ontario the mounties and border services
will take the appropriate steps
ontario's liberal leader says ford must
do more than that doug ford's been in
hiding weak statements tweets that were
likely written by other people that's
not leadership in the midst of a crisis
now it's time to let the people in
ottawa get back to their lives that was
more than a week ago when ford last took
questions on camera about the protests
one reason for ford's low profile an
election just months away says this
analyst he doesn't want to
necessarily come out and embrace the the
various activities but at the same time
he doesn't want to polarize anybody
who's sympathetic to him ontario public
health plans to recommend lifting some
covid restrictions next week but not
because protesters are demanding it
without any external pressure because i
don't really watch the news too much
we are
absolutely committed
to removing public health measures in a
timely evidence-based science driven
science driven manner across the country
governments are shifting ground on covid
restrictions it is time to remove these
restrictive and damaging health measures
alberta the first to drop vaccine
mandates others are resisting pressure
to do so too quickly one of the most
important things that we have now on our
side is that tool of protection through
vaccination we're still a lot out of
this one epidemiologist is worried that
amid the protests trust in science is
being politicized as a result we have
protesters
fringe thinking that seems to be
dictating some of this policy
and not surprisingly the policy is
falling along ideological lines for
governments and police there's
reluctance to be heavy-handed with
so-called freedom protests but with
supply chains being disrupted the
incentive to take action is growing that
could give politicians far more licensed
to get involved without being you know
seen to be cracking down on freedom but
instead being trying to defend the
economy back in ontario the attorney
general obtained a court order late
today to prohibit anyone from disposing
of or dealing with monetary donations
through the freedom convoy and adopt a
trucker campaign by way of the give send
go online fundraising platform eric
sorensen global news toronto